[Musique]
je vis depuis l'âge de 15 ans dans un
univers peuplé de doux dingues qui
partagent une passion relativement
déraisonnable pour une activité qui
consiste à monter en avion à 4000 mètres
et un redescendre sans l'avion ou bien à
tourner en rond dans un tube en
plexiglas tel un poisson dans un bocal
je vous la corde c'est un peu spécial et
pourtant ces doux dingues il adore ça
alors qu'est ce qui peut bien pousser un
être humain à se jeter d'un avion en
parfait état de marche de son plein gré
pourquoi quelqu'un en pleine possession
de ses capacités intellectuelles
voudrait-il s'enfermer dans une
soufflerie verticale dans du vent à 250
kilomètres heure
c'est ce que j'aimerais explorer avec
vous aujourd'hui en vous embarquant dans
mon univers en ouvrant une fenêtre sur
ce sport méconnu quel parachutisme
sportif
pour ça je vais commencer par vous
emmener avec moi dans un seau le dernier
record du monde féminin de grandes
formations vertical qui consiste à
réaliser tête en bas la plus grande
frayeur accrochées les unes aux autres
vous êtes prêts
on est en novembre en arizona fait froid
je porte une combinaison longue avec pas
mal de couches en dessous des gants et
des chaufferettes à l'intérieur un
casque intégral
je me tiens debout à côté d'un sky
vannes mes amis dans le nord appelle ça
une baraque à frites avec des ailes pour
vous donner une idée de l'élégance de
l'aéronef
les hélices tournante et tonitruante
propulse un souffle d'air chaud
hoogerland kérosène autour de moi
soixante quatre autres femmes
s'apprêtent à embarquer dans les trois
avions de la flotte je monte dans le sky
vannes et je m'installe assise par terre
de aux pilotes serré contre mes
coéquipières j'attache ma ceinture je
vérifier un petit tube en plastique qui
pendent du plafond important pour la
suite
les deux dernières embarquée montrent
refaire la porte en la tirant vers le
bas et la verrouillant on est prêtes
pour le décollage
on va monter à 6000 mètres pour ce soit
la durée la montée va durer à peu près
45 les pilotes aline les avions sur la
piste de décollage et c'est parti à
travers le hublot la paire s'éloigne le
familier devient distants on entre dans
une parenthèse
cette montée en avion c'est un sas vers
un autre monde un monde où les humains
pendant quelques secondes d'éternité
peuvent voler
la pression monte je me concentre sur
mon saut pour discipliner mon esprit je
visualise tout le saut à venir du début
à la fin en point de vue interne d'abord
ce que je vais voir ce que je vais
ressentir et ensuite on point de vue
externe alors quand on visualise c'est
très important de se concentrer sur ce
qu'on veut faire et pas sur ce qu'on a
peur de mal faire quand on visualise nos
cerveaux ne retiennent pas la négation
si je vous dis ne pensez surtout pas un
éléphant rose
donc je me concentre sur le saut parfait
arrivé à peu près à mi-chemin à 3000 m
les fameux petits tubes en plastique
commencé à distribuer de l'oxygène alors
3000 mètres c'est l'altitude à laquelle
l'oxygène se raréfie si vous allez faire
un saut ce week-end ce que je vous
souhaite vous allez monter à 4000 mètres
c'est l'attitude standard à peu près
partout dans le monde ça donne une
minute de chute libre
là vous passez moins de cinq minutes au
dessus de 3000 m vous n'avez pas besoin
d'oxygène supplémentaire et pour un saut
comme celui ci on va monter jusqu'à 6000
mètres pour grappiller des secondes de
chute libre pour pouvoir réaliser ce
record est bien là on a besoin
d'apporter un complément pour lutter
contre ce qu'on appelle l'hypoxie
l'hypoxie tout simplement c'est un
manque d'apport en oxygène au niveau des
tissus de l'organisme
on fonctionne vachement moins bien
on arrive bientôt à notre altitude de
largage simultanément dans les trois
avions une lumière rouge s'allume
c'est le signal pour nous dire qu'on est
à deux minutes je me redresse j'ai
vérifié mon matériel une dernière fois
jette un coup d'oeil à celui des copines
on échange quelques regards le
connivence d'encouragement
lumière jaune une minute du largage
la porte s'ouvre
6 km sous nos pieds le désert d'arizona
un vent glacial s'engouffre dans
l'habitacle mon rythme cardiaque
s'accélère
alors j'ai plus peur de sauter ça ça a
disparu pour moi au bout d'une
cinquantaine de saut il ya bien
longtemps maintenant mais j'ai le trac
stress de performance alors je respire
calmement je me rappelle que
techniquement je sais faire qu'il faut
juste que je me concentre je pense aux
gens que j'aime et dont le soutien me
donne de la force à chaque expiration je
pense à ceux dont je veux me débarrasser
du stress doute
à chaque inspiration au contraire à ce
dont je veux m'imprégner confiance en
moi efficacité de mon vol solidité
lumière verte showtime je suis prête à
bondir ma coéquipière amy responsable du
signal du départ
cris pour se faire entendre par dessus
le bruit du vent et des moteurs ready
set go je cours vers l'arrière de
l'appareil je prends une dernière
impulsion sur le plancher et je saute
gainées de au sol j'entre dans mon
élément
alors ce qu'on appelle voler en
parachutisme
c'est en fait se mouvoir dans le vent
relatif qui est un terme qui décrit le
vent subie par un objet en mouvement au
moment où on sort de l'avion on rentre
en fait dans le vent relatif du
déplacement de l'avion lui même le vent
et horizontale et puis au bout de 4 5
secondes une phase qu'on appelle la
projection j'entre dans le vent relatif
de ma propre chute merci la gravité là
le vent vient du sol il est vertical on
n'a pas du tout l'impression de tomber
dans le vide quand on est en chute libre
je sais que c'est pas intuitif mais
c'est un peu comme quand vous mettez
votre main en dehors de la voiture sur
l'autoroute vous sentez la pression de
l'air et voilà c'est la même chose mais
surtout votre corps on encore un peu
plus fort sauf si vous faites vraiment
de très gros excès de vitesse
donc j'ai pas du tout l'impression de
tomber dans le vide j'ai cette sensation
de pression sur tout le corps et les
positions que je vais prendre les
mouvements que je vais donner tout ça ça
va induire des accélérations des
freinages ou des déplacements c'est un
peu comme apprendre à nager vous évoluez
dans un élément qui a une texture
dès la sortie d'avion jeu convergent
vers le coeur de la formation une ronde
à 4 qu'on appelle la base moi je fais
partie des quatre personnes qui sortent
indépendamment de cette base et qui
allons rentrer à l'intérieur pour en
faire une ronde à 8 pour en faire un
socle plus grand pour la figure
autour de nous les participantes sac du
team en revenant attrapé de leurs mains
le bras de celle arrivée avant elle
elles prennent place dans ce puzzle
géant en plein ciel
les vitesses de vent sont fortes on a à
peu près à 280 km heure les résistances
sont assez impressionnantes en plus de
ça je me fais un peu chahuté par les
appontages successifs il faut que ce
soit à la fois solide et souple dans mon
vol
chez le 16e sceau de la semaine tout le
monde est fatigué pour un record soit
validée il faut que l'intégralité des
participants soit la place exacte qui
leur a été attribué sur le dessin qu'on
a soumis au juge avant de monter dans
l'avion donc tout le monde de réaliser
le saut parfait sur le même saut aussi
une personne n'est pas à sa place le
record est pas validé on doit remonter
donc la pression est vraiment forte sur
tout le monde c'est stressant mais ça
vous met aussi dans un profond état de
flou ça vous fait opérer au maximum de
vos capacités ça c'est vraiment grisant
soudain tout s'apaise en face de moi la
figure et complète et quand je vois les
sourires sur les visages en face de moi
je comprends que c'est pareil derrière
moi ces moments sont d'une force
incroyable c'est comme si un courant
électrique parcours et la formation
comme si la joie pouvait transférer par
le toucher
même si leurs corps sont validées le
sauver pas terminé en 10 secondes qui
vont suivre sans super importante
d'abord on va devoir se séparer les unes
des autres pour que chaque parachutistes
puisse aller ouvrir sa voile dans son
coin de ciel alors on a à l'intérieur de
nos casques un petit boîtier qu'on
appelle un altimètre sonore oups bipe
dans lequel on peut régler plusieurs
sonneries à différentes altitudes donc
ça nous permet de régler les moments
auxquels on va pouvoir s'éloigner les
unes des autres
il ya une première vague qui va partir à
peu près à 2200 mètres l'extérieur de la
figure qui fait demi tour et qui
s'éloigne le reste continue de chuter
verticalement une deuxième vague à 2000
mètres et enfin vers 1700 m la troisième
vague celle qui est au coeur de la
formation celle dont je fais partie je
fais 1 180 par rapport au centre et je
pars en dérive du sol quand vous
regardez ça ça ressemble un feu
d'artifice ans jusqu'aux voile qui
s'ouvre dans un crépitement
une fois sauvages restent vigilantes 65
personnes qui veulent se poser sur le
même petit carré d'herbe ça fait du
monde je pilote ma voile prudemment et
je rejoins la terre ferme moins de trois
minutes se sont écoulées entre le moment
où j'ai sauté de l'avion et le moment où
mes pieds touchent le sol
une fois posée j'exulte mes coéquipières
avec moi c'est comme ça c'est des années
de préparation de 5 il s'entend en
argent la semaine en plus ça a été
difficile il a fait froid tout ça c'est
récompenser dans une explosion de
bonheur je vous montre à quoi ça
ressemble
[Musique]
m
ce
[Musique]
à
et
vous l'avez reconnu la foldingue ce
partout à la fin de la vidéo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors je sais que pour beaucoup ce sport
a une image extrême dangereuse c'est
vrai les accidents ça arrive comme dans
tous les aspects de la vie mais en
parachutisme les sauts qui sont
effectués d'avions y en a vraiment peu
rapporté au nombre de sauts effectués
chaque année
la pratique a énormément évolué nos
matériels aussi aujourd'hui nos
parachute sont hyper fiable on a deux
voiles une principale ici et une voile
de secours on a même un petit boîtier à
l'intérieur des parachutes qui prend en
compte votre vitesse et votre altitude
qui va ouvrir automatiquement votre
voile de secours si vous avez pas ouvert
la principale attend si vous êtes tombé
dans les pommes par exemple si vous êtes
fait mal aux bras et que vous n'arrivez
pas à ouvrir si vous avez oublié
l'attitude ça devrait pas arriver mais
ça arrive
la soufflerie c'est aussi un moyen
génial d'apprendre à voler vous y
découvrez les chances à sion de la chute
libre exactement pareil qu'un saut en
parachute et vous n'avez ni a sauté de
l'avion ni à piloter et posé une voile
qui sont souvent les plus gros facteur
de stress quand on commence alors
pourquoi est-ce qu'on saute pourquoi est
ce que je souhaite
d'abord j'adore voler j'aime la
sensation physique du vent sur mon corps
l'intense impression de liberté pour
cent quand on est dans les airs
j'aime voir la terre vue du ciel la
beauté des paysages la lumière dorée
d'un coucher de soleil en plein ciel le
parachutisme a vraiment une esthétique
unique
j'aime la créativité que permettent les
disciplines le free fly en saut d'avion
et le dynamique en soufflerie comme ce
que vous voyez là à l'écran ont créé des
chorégraphies en trois dimensions avec
une liberté totale de mouvement et
d'orientation c'est vraiment unique ça
aussi
j'aime transmettre ce que j'ai appris
vie voire en plein vol la mine extatique
de quelqu'un à qui ai-je apprend à voler
et puis j'aime ma tribu je peux dire
sans l'ombre d'un doute qu'elle aimait
plus grande force
ma plus grande source d'inspiration
c'est un grand mix un bouillon de
cultures et de milieux sociaux des gens
qui viennent de partout relié par ce
truc complètement improbable et fils à
jo et sincèrement démultiplier quand
elle est partagée c'est vrai pour
n'importe quel saut et ça l'est encore
plus pour les sauts de grandes
formations comme celui qu'on vient de
vivre ensemble ils sont des défis et
donc des succès collectif
en plus de ce sentiment d'appartenance
bref très fort cette vie dans les airs
m'a permis de vivre une succession folle
de moments et d'expériences originales
j'ai connu l'intensité les efforts et la
détermination qui mène un titre de
champion du monde avec ce saut que vous
êtes en train de voir l'écran à dubaï en
2012 j'ai parcouru la planète grâce à
mon sport
lundi dernier j'étais en train de
réviser mon talk les pieds dans le sable
dans le ca après cela
j'ai survolé fidji le sud du portugal
les alpes le burning man beaucoup trop
de photos pour tout vous les montrer ce
serait pas très drôle et puis en 18
minutes j'aurais pas du tout le temps
j'ai découvert l'entrepreneuriat il ya
deux ans en ouvrant avec quatre de mes
amis une soufflerie à poitiers il ya
quelques mois j'ai même faire un saut
dans une robe de haute couture
si on m'avait dit un jour que je serais
à la fashion week de paris et dans vogue
avec en toile de fond de touche à la
liberté totale de construire mon
calendrier est qu heureux de la liberté
que je ressens quand je vole
enfin et c'est là pour moi la raison la
plus importante la plus personnelle
voler c'est le biais par lequel j'ai
décidé de répondre à la question comment
réussir ma vie
j'ai grandi entouré de livres et cette
confrontation à une multitude
d'intériorité a fait naître en moi le
désir de connaître le plus
exhaustivement possible l'expérience
humaine
javier cercas un écrivain espagnol a dit
que pour lui la littérature c'était une
façon de vivre encore plus de façon plus
complexe plus intense je suis
profondément d'accord avec ça et c'est
la même force qui me pousse à dévorer
des livres que celle qui m'a poussé à
sauter d'un avion pour la première fois
à 15 ans alors que rien dans mon
environnement familial denis prédispose
ce sport à capturer mon coeur et la vie
à laquelle il m'a donné accès à justifie
pour moi les risques mesurés que je
prends le pratiquant et je parle pas
juste des risques inhérents à l'activité
le choix d'une carrière sportive dans un
sport pas du tout médiatisé en tant que
travailleuse indépendante c'était un
risque et pourtant là aussi sauté le pas
a été la condition sinequanone à la vie
que je mène aujourd'hui et qui me rend
profondément heureuse
c'est un cliché pourtant c'est vrai
votre plus belle vie vous attend de
l'autre côté de vos peurs il s'agit pas
de prendre des risques inconsidérés à
tout bout de champ allez vous n'êtes
même pas obligé vous jeter d'un avion en
parfait état de marche
le monde dans son incroyable diversité
regorge de source d'émerveillement
il suffit que vous trouviez celles qui
font chanter votre coeur et puis ensuite
que vous trouviez le courage de les
explorer
parce que quand on cherche à insuffler
dans sa vie de l'extraordinaire malgré
ses peurs la vie est plus belle
[Applaudissements]